I love evolve because it's just it's so
much simpler than going out shopping
just going shopping online and love all
the brands that have sent me the Holden
holiday collection everything was really
beautiful and it was hard actually to
pick which one I was gonna wear tonight
you were the queen of fashion is there a
fashion rule that you love to break I
like making my own rules you've always
been that type where I like to start
trends and not follow them yeah it's
been fun to see you a little bit on
Keeping Up with the Kardashians when are
we gonna see you full-time back on
reality TV like do you ever miss it do
you ever think about it people offer me
different shows like every single day
I'm gonna get something but I'm so busy
running my empire I don't have time but
I've actually been shooting the past
full year of my entire life for my new
documentary that's coming out the
beginning of the year what are we gonna
learn about you in this documentary is
going to be the untold story people are
going to be very surprised when are we
gonna get a Kim Paris BFF cake a beauty
collection you guys talk about
I can't tell any secret
are you dating right now are you looking
for luck I'm really good right now I'm
just focusing on my life my business
hanging off my girlfriends and having
the time of my life new music yes
there's no music coming up when we're
shooting a music video next week so some
singles coming out with the nervo twins
very soon
[Music]